[Music]
hey guys
why am i excited about tribe mentors
what makes it different well this is a
cookbook and encyclopedia of tactics
that are immediately actionable tools
that are immediately actionable so you
have probably 20 plus billionaire's
20 plus world-class athletes every
possible area you can imagine people
talking to you what they do when they
get overwhelmed the specific self-talk
and actions they take when they're
trying to say decline something say no
so they don't get over committed how
they exercise in the mornings how they
work out on the road how they've planned
for breaking records for 10 X 800 Xing
results so with any flip of any page you
should be able to find something that'll
change your life and do so quickly so
good luck and enjoy hey guys if you're
enjoying the tips and tactics and how-to
on this channel or in the podcast the
Tim Ferriss show I made this for you
try the mentors short advice from the
best in the world this is the book that
I wanted to read so I went out and I put
it together created a dream list a
hundred and thirty of the best at what
they do people who are icons legends and
ask them all the same questions these
are people in some cases I wanted to
reach out to my whole life ranges from
many many billionaires cofounders of
every company imaginable elite athletes
ranging from surfing to tennis to
powerlifting everything else country
stars actors directors and you can spot
the pattern so some of my friends have
said this is the easiest to read most
useful book that I've put together yet
so check it out tribe of mentors dot-com
you can find sample chapters the whole
list of mentors everything tribe mentors
calm